non monsieur
je pense bête bonjour là on a deux cas
on a deux cas mais clairement là dans la
profession sport ajoute sébastien
bannier là et on a les trois les trois
plus grands ce qu'on fait mazarine
pingeot ce qu'ont fait les frais ils ont
tous fait donc voila merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous merci nous avons invité
et d'avoir le courage aussi d'être avec
nous parce que j'aille en a qui sont pas
toujours pas voilà de très non c'est
vous qui êtes courageux de nous inviter
on n'est plus et paparazzi on est des
papiers radio jour
par exemple jacques chirac c'est vous
jacques chirac c'était quoi s'est ténue
vous avez raison il ya une photo qui a
été fait à brégançon où le président est
nu pourquoi parce que quand le président
se trouve à brégançon il ya évidemment
une interdiction de survol et dans la
nuit à le bateau d'un yacht de
schumacher qui était dans la baie à côté
et le matin et un hélicoptère qui
décolle qu'est-ce qu'il fait chirac qui
sortent son lit il soit la fenêtre et
nous on est en bas on fait des photos
mais ces photos on les a jamais diffusé
à jamais jamais jamais non non vous avez
tous les trucs du genre jamais plus allé
écraser tard à nancy patients âgés
c'est génial cranage ça se garde en cas
de
chirac un jour il m'a dit rostaing
finalement vous êtes un gain est patent
personne n'a jamais dit que j'étais pas
tant elle vous a déjà dit que vous étiez
épatant non
parce qu'il vous reconnaissez à chaque
fois il commence à vous connaître
finalement oui parce que j'avais réussi
à pénétrer aussi pendant deux jours et
deux nuits un sommet ultra garder c'est
à dire le g8 pendant deux jours et deux
nuits j'étais avec bush poutine chirac
tony blair mais c'est quoi le g8 ces
huit potes qui passent un week-end se
ressent leur bonne femme il parle de
quoi il parle de ce
que j'avais fait des photos incroyables
et chirac un jour me croisent à la
mamounia et mehdi rostain comment vous
avez pour avoir une chambre à
l'intérieur d'eux g8 ma fille claude
n'avait pas de chambre gilles monsieur
le président je vais vous l'expliquer
c'est un secret et j'ai dit il ya une
photo quand même il dit comme non il
m'avait demandé comment vous avez
comment les présidents les huit ont fait
pour choisir les photos cdj il fallait
me faire confiance il m'a dit reste à
vous faire confiance voilà un nouveau
concept que
jamais vous avez tort monsieur le
président parce qu'il ya une photo c'est
juste après ce moment là il ya une photo
souvenez vous vous êtes en train
d'expliquer comment au salut au japon en
fonction de la personne en face de qui
vous êtes et pour déconner cuse a mis
les deux plus rôle c'était benito et
berlusconi et le premier ministre du
japon et pour déconner le premier
ministre du japon met un genou à terre
et devant bush il dit est tellement
important et il se met presque à plat
ventre tu fais la photo je rentre à
paris tu développes les photos et là tu
dis bien il ya un truc qui s'appelle
quand même hiroshima nagasaki
le premier ministre du japon à genoux
devant le président des états unis si tu
sors la photo le mec qui soit hara-kiri
mais vraiment je n'aime pas et donc j'ai
brûlé la photo et quand j jacques chirac
c'est là où il m'a dit ah finalement
vous êtes un gars est palpable
le c'est pas le plus merde
je m'attendais à tout nouveau niveau de
nouveautés de leur technologie mais pas
d'isabelle encore la vfr oui alors le
plus gros coup c'est quoi le plus gros
coup c'est pas un plus gros coup c'est à
dire que c'est vrai que il ya une
période où ce qui était intéressant
c'est ce qui intéressait les médias et
donc le public de dans les pays dans le
monde entier et c'était la famille
royale angleterre c'est lé monaco la
famille princière monaco et daniel
angeli qui est quand même notre maître à
tous est le roi des paparazzi oui on a
fait quelques uns aussi absolument alors
justement d un gilet vous en avez fait
quelques-uns notamment effectivement
ballon j'adore brigitte bardot
wabush du bardo tout le monde l'a fait
ça c'est vous et non pas du tout c'est
daniel sans ma fille je sais pas vous
mais chercher les pdq pendant très
longtemps dans votre dans votre cas
c'est ce à quoi
moi il est diffusé chez moi
j'attends votre plus gros coup à vous
moi c'est ça faire une fine qui se
félicitent les pieds
oui ça comment vous les germes et un peu
la couronne
il n'a rien et ça honnêtement est-ce
qu'on peut parler aujourd'hui c'est
comment ça vous a rapporté sa optimistes
auront un petit rire tu mettais tout
dépenser
[Rires]
n'importe quoi waouh vieux on parle on
était en francs à l'époque mais alors
c'est difficile mais allez on va dire 3
4 millions d'euros cinq
noms de rues où il a planqué quand même
pendant deux ou trois heures oui
d'euros il ya les agents qu'il faut
payer way qui vendent des photos à
l'étranger il ya tout un tas de trucs
j'en ai fait deux pour vous quoi les
minima il reste sur balles
je crois qu'ils le fassent et la baie la
reine d'angleterre voilà c'est ça quand
elle est belle fille de la reine
d'angleterre absolument
behague donc le ter qui nous avaient
recherché d'ores et déjà les vous
planquer c'est ça en suisse ah oui après
j'étais plein oui j'étais l'arroseur
arrosé
c'est à dire que les anglais comme
j'avais fais couler me
menaçait me planque est venu chez moi
quand j'en ai mes gosses à l'école et
une chute
des photos qui ont été interdites
notamment en france est que vous avez
fait qu'on pas pu être vendus j'aimerais
d'abord avant votre votre avis parce que
ça vient de sortir ça cette semaine
ouais c'était une qu'on a vu un qui est
apparu aujourd'hui sur eric zemmour
voilà et sna fu ils ont perdu leur bébé
est-ce que c'est tunnel vous choque
est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
notamment de la manière dont on traite
peut-être les les hommes politiques
aujourd'hui où ça pendant cette élection
et moi je sais pas parce que
de ma génération tous les présidents
comme chirac et cetera j'aime j'ai fait
plus de rendez-vous que planck ont fait
à huy alors donc
c'est jean jacques nozach était
directeur de photo magazine qui a fait
une une et un portfolio et kim m'a collé
une étiquette que le roi des paparazzi
ouais c'est vrai mais c'est pas tout
mais transitoire reconnu que c'est toi
c'est moi
oui mais là les connaît tous sa le
prince isabelle elle les connaît tous sa
pour les
bons à vsd on attend on travaillait
beaucoup à voir qu'il n'est pas paradis
les grandes fois paradis donc 1 on a
travaillé avec vous un à vsd et des fois
les photos nous coûter si cher qu'on est
obligé d'enlever d'autres reportages bon
allez mieux parce qu'il fallait rentrent
à l'origine je vous dis que pascal que
je connais depuis très très longtemps et
parce qu'on fait pas que des plants par
exemple laurent j'ai fait des photos
officielles avec lui rendez vous en fin
de nuit ciel on s'en fout la faute au
gala des trucs à fait comme ça m'a un
jour on m'a dit que c'est toi pascal qui
avait fait la photo de qena faux et
zemmour dans l'eau à la une de paris
match oui elle est pas de signer la
photo mais vous savez
on ne sait pas c'est vous les rênes oui
c'est sûr mais oui mais oui c'est lui -
photo dr
on
découvre des rumeurs
c'est j'ai quand même justifier quelque
chose est sûre sur les le jour où cette
une de paris match est sorti eh ben il
est rentré dans un club très fermé dans
le club très fermé des présidents de la
république qui ont fait la couverte de
paris-match en maillot de bain
et une boisson ouais c'est évident et
normal c'est évidemment toi qui avais
cette photo et on m'a dit que c'est bien
content quand j'ai vu ces photos comme
tout le monde le 6 et paparazzi ou pas
et en fait on m'a dit attends c'est
pascal rostain qui les suivait déjà
depuis deux jours donc tu es tu arrivé
le matin pour shooter là sur la plage tu
étais avec eux officiellement
[Applaudissements]
tout d'un coup tu te dis comté zee et sa
femme sa future femme animée et que tu
sais que ta pascal rostain constants le
pôle pas qu'elle paiera 10 par eux à
créditer tu faisais rien que cette photo
là elle va tomber un moment donné non tu
les amapiens
jamais comment ça s'est passé ça s'est
passé cette guerre non ça c'est passé
d'une fête organisée à 83 journalistes
accrédités lors de son premier
déplacement à toulon et à nice et le
matin même une bédard façon dire comme
nous envoie un message il y avait une
des ans bull à sion prévu sur le marché
aux fleurs de nice à midi un message en
disant c'est annulé tu te promènes sur
la plage est une et voit tous les deux
que ce que tu fais tu fais des photos
elle est simple alors c'est vrai que
quand s'étaient accrédités et que
j'avais fait un rendez vous avec lui pas
avec avec lui la veille les gens dit
mais c'est bizarre il a fait un rendez
vous donc ils sont mais s'ils sont pas
de mèche quoi cette plante si nous vous
rappelons que c'est une fausse planque
en tous les cas ce jour là c'est là je
déconne pas présidentialiser parce que
si tu regardes les unes de paris
maintient avec les présidents de la
république en maillot de bain bayahi
chirac qui a eu sarkozy il ya eu
françois hollande
salue le cache pas elle fait une fois à
poil dans paris match
rappelle toi c'est toi qui a fait la
photo de la femme de sarkozy à new york
en train de choisir son nouvel événement
etc richard attias ce
que le patron de paris match à l'époque
la verte a laissé passer il l'a rappelé
vandana u2 celle là aussi et moi je suis
toujours à paris match c'est vraiment
dégueulasse et paris match quand elle
achète cette photo là justement de
sarkozy elle se doute pas du tout ce qui
va se passer de ces scheer cécile après
c'était compliqué parce qu'à l'époque
faut pas oublier que l'informateur
s'appelait nicolas sarkozy ah oui bah
oui comment comment on était au courant
de cette histoire il donne une interview
à france 3 bourgogne et il dit comme
beaucoup de français en ce moment j'ai
des difficultés dans mon couple ouais
bon je veux dire la l'info à l'éclair
ouais donc c'est vrai que la presse
beaucoup de journalistes savaient qu'il
y avait cette histoire avec richard
attias s'il y avait déjà eu des photos
on avait déjà fait d'autres photos
d'ailleurs et pourquoi au dernier moment
paris-match décide de faire sa une parce
qu'on avait une information que vsd oui
allait sortir l'histoire que j'avais
appelé philippe labi à l'époque le
directeur de vsd pour vérifier il m'a
dit oui on sort l'histoire sauf qu'ils
sortaient d'histoire dans le texte mais
pas en photo d'accord et c'est là où
paris match a réagi très rapidement
j'aimerais aussi vu qu'on parle d'un
coup je suis obligé de raconter cette
histoire ce qu'on va parler des fausses
paparazzades aussi nicolas sarkozy faut
savoir qu'au moment peu avant l'élection
présidentielle où il est élu on lui a
reproché d'être de trop peopolisé sa vie
est en fait j'ai juste avant l'émission
philippe varin qui était son photographe
officiel à l'époque qui m'a dit nicolas
sarkozy lui a demandé lui même de faire
une photo pour les retrouvailles avec
cécilia mais que ce soit une photo une
paparazzade arranger donc ils sont tous
partis à londres et ils ont fait la
photo là bas sur place une photo alors
qui est présenté comme une parade parade
qui n'en est pas une et j'aimerais qu'on
parle aussi maintenant maintenant des
fausses paparazzades parce que ça se
connaît aussi je vous donne l apport
dans un instant me direz ça existe
encore mais chaque jour me toi tu en as
vécu vraiment ça moi ce n'est pas une
fausse paparazzade chine est une ex de
castaldi nextag de castaldi qui un jour
mais proposer et mehdi puisqu'on va être
papa radier avec avec avec benjamin
plutôt que donner l'argent à un
paparazzi qu'on connaît pas bien avec
nous tu fais les photos dès le premier
jour et cetera tu vend les photos tout
de suite je crois que ce soit toi ton
touche plutôt qu'un paparazzi qu'on
connaît à lamia et puis en fait il est
plus je n'ai pas fait ou ne fait pas
fait parce que voilà ça marcherait pas
voilà mais une autre fois en gt gt copan
ya une quinzaine avec un chanteur très
connu français qui devait partir avec sa
petite amie naviner mine puisqu'il était
mariée et n'a fidélité et devait partir
aux seychelles pour un grand week-end et
du queens dit jean michel tu veux pas ni
avec moi aux seychelles
est libre mais j'ai pas large et pas
largement t'inquiète pas je paye tout
jeu bah oui évidemment je dis oui là il
me dit parce que si je pars avec ma
petite copine évidemment comme les les
hôtesses à l'embarquement air france dès
qu'il ya un people qui m'a il appelle
évidemment les journaux disent en est
athènes dès qu'on arrivait les reports à
l'arrivée on est déjà tendu par les
photographes ils ont uni tu fais croire
que c'est ta petite copine tout le temps
sauf quand on rentre à l'hôtel mais là
tu me l'as tu me la refuse
donc à la plage meute rabat les bras
dessus bras dessous où c'est
lui il disait à côté et enfin des cours
très bas je me sens il
urban truck et et chaque fois que vous
avez qu'une brève aux paparazzi vous
avez fait la une de voici non pas une
fausse vraie bah oui et vous étiez
comment avec qui j'étais avec eux ils
s'appellent qui était mama
banon a bien aimé
avec votre âme ouais isabelle est gelée
ne sépare et demi qu'il s'est pas encore
totalement officiel on a été en vacances
voilà et à quoi on reconnaît une fausse
paparazzade une vraie bonne rasade je
peux vous dire que moi j'aurais accepté
aucune des photos qui ont été diffusées
étaient que des photos de dos oublié mon
guide ses théories je pense que j'aurais
demandé à ma être coupé un peu
différemment alors oui il est sain de ma
nouvelle femme et tes seins nus ouais
mais ça existe encore ça rend du coup ou
pas parce qu'on
écoute moi je peux voir parler parce que
personnellement j'ai jamais fait de
fausses paparazzades fn a fait daniel
liccioni johnny c'est drôle parce que
c'était johnny est ici j'en étais en
vacances ensemble
à l'île maurice rey et il avait un
jacuzzi devant leur leur chambre bon
chic et
on s'arrange avec johnny et laeticia et
aux dit on va faire une une série vous
embrassiez thua thien-hué bras et c'est
donc je suis pas parti à longueur de 200
mm pas très loin derrière un petit
bosquet et j'ai commencé photopiles
adieu johnny tu tapes dans les mains ils
m'appellent disent c'est pas une
paparazzade parce que je te vois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable parce
que tu vois je m'en souvenais pas mais
avant que tu deviennes sans photographe
officiel il nous avait appelés un jour
inédit il faudrait que tu viennes faire
les photos de paparazzi enfin la
couverture de le voici parce que ce
connard de camus il n'a pas vendu les
plages de le concert à dieu je dis ok
mais pour la couverture de voici faut
une nouvelle fiancée il m'a dit qu'est
ce que tu crois je suis avec la miss
france hadji a bon qu'elle millésime
g cake l année et là il est adoré vite
inquiète pas c'est pas geneviève de
fontenay
et j'arrive le lendemain matin il
habitait villa molitor donc tu vois
c'était y'a quand même il ya il ya pas
mal de temps et il dit tu viens le matin
j'arrive à 8 heures mais j'ai pas le
même curseur que johnny il sort à 16
heures avec ça il prend les quais et là
ils font sam sem je l'appelle j ml
écoute pascal je connais les paparazzi
dechantre open je connais les paparazzi
de l'étude toi tu fais pas bien le
paparazzi
[Rires]
inquiète je vais essayer de te retrouver
il me dit ça m'étonnerait je suis né
dans le 9ème arrondissement de paris
jeudi et quels rapports et puis je
connais les 20 arrondissements que paris
c'est très grand que tu peux pas me
retrouver jumeaux dès que cette nouvelle
fiancée tulameen avenue de la grande
armée chez western house et tu la
déguisant pocahontas à ali mais comment
que tu sais quand elles avaient agi
parce que je suis un bon babarazzi et
donc il est sorti l'un minutes après on
était là et elle avait là la chemise en
daim avec les frangins
ma vie dit elle et c'est y aller en
train d'essayer les justin en orne bac
c'est quoi voilà et bizi tu connais ne
dise il se trouve que je connais la
boutique ne dise à los angeles dans la
vallée quelle boutique de santiags
justin c'est une marque de 100 sièges
dit m le handbike je connais pas il me
dit t'es pas un cow-boy j non c'est du
lézard à crête gipoulou du lézard funk
ça va être coquette et prévisionnel est
donc fausse paparazzade donc ça reste
vous revient quand même une fois aux
tripotages
10 sur johnny parce que c'est la légende
dans la presse people dit que johnny
était celui qui n'attaquait jamais la
presse people est ce qu'il disait tout
le temps peu importe l'essentiel c'est
comparer dévoilée par contre a contrario
jeu rebondit aussi sur les fausses
paparazzades il ya une comédienne une
par une présentatrice sur sur une grande
chaîne nationale qui est une une
coudière du fait et elle a la
particularité d'attaquer ses propres
fausse paparazzade ne donnerait pas son
identité à une telle chaîne
nationale donc je peux vous dire qu'il
s'agit pas on serait tous attaqué là ce
serait compliqué que je vois et voilà
donc c'est pour ça il y en a qui
n'attaque pas parce qu'ils estiment
qu'on parle de ces chouettes et y en
ad'autres les mains couvertes indécent
calment tout ça pour dire mathieu
répondre à ta question ça existe encore
oui et elle oui vous êtes moi j'ai
beaucoup vécu ça avec jean l'une des
leurs et me dit regarde bien quand tu me
vois la une de voici et que je suis fera
ce que c'est une fausse et une vraie
paparazzade quand j'ai les tablettes de
chocolat que je suis en train de faire
crapahuter c'est qu'un accord avec moi
c'est incroyable c'est quand même
si quand il est arrivé j'étais sur la
plage avec quelqu'un de très connu
c'était pas moi j'ai des paparazzis à
faire la personne connue et lui dit
voilà on a des photos de vous
soluto moyenne vous n'êtes pas très beau
donc soit vous retourner dans l'eau vous
sortez ont fait de jolis série à quoi le
sens des glaces à génial j'ai voit la
journée
alors j'ai couru dans l'aude
mais lille a dit jamais jamais jamais de
vrais des compromis publiez ce que vous
voulez j'attaquerai effectivement lui
était dégueulasse
les poteaux sont sortis comme un appel
dans quelques secondes
ce n'est pas par hasard d'arranger ossio
n'allait pas par hasard et je pense je
pense aux plus connus ou inconnus mais
ça peut être de kiss le le bisou de
diana sur un bateau où daniel ducruet et
daniel ducruet c'était une paparazzade
totalement arrangé pour lesquels ils
vont vers les accords musicale ou pas ah
oui ça c'est d'abord c'est pas un
journaliste qui a fait ça parce qu'il
n'a pas de carte de presse ouais c'est
une escroquerie c'est quelque chose
qu'on réprouve totalement c'est déjà un
métier pas facile à défendre aussi
maintenant on organise quelque chose
c'était un piège s'était même pas du
cospar azad par contre me baiser de
diana et dodi al fayed c'est une vraie
vraie paparazzade et puisqu'on est là le
prévenu tout le monde non non non non
non je suis veuf j'ai prévenu
voilà d'accord qui s'appelle mario
brunet hockey et c'est lui qui a fait
moi j'ai abandonné parce que j'ai plus
d'essence dans mon bateau on partait de
saint tropez puisque en sardaigne pour
claire donc j'ai appelé mario il a fait
ça
[ __ ] et sébastien vallée la caisse à 6
millions d'euros sinon 6 millions la
flotte c3 de la précédente mais vous
vous posez combien niveau du pont mais
il s'étend il a tout prévu il a tiré
quémander du fruit d' pour venir à et
michou
moi je avant qu'on se fasse virer parce
qu'il va nous foute dehors dans pas
longtemps je tenais à dire à ceux qui
aiment ce genre de photos que
aujourd'hui ces photos sont accrochées
dans des musées et des expositions dans
le monde entier dire on a même exposé au
centre pompidou et en ce moment il ya
une exposition au dernier étage de la
grande arche de la défense
rétrospective de toutes les photos de la
nasa est vraiment extraordinaire c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut aller
voir et bientôt toutes ces photos seront
dnf t vous savez ce que c'est d'arriver
assuré c'est cette nouvelle façon de de
commercialiser un document en vendant un
fichier original chaque les personnes
qui achètent le nfc en devient le
propriétaire la ferguson pour l'habitat
leur celle que tu as fait c'est une c
est alors j'ai dû moi j'ai une anecdote
donc j'appelle va hélas parce que je
voulais qu'il est sur ce plateau et au
maroc il me raconte 2,3 et par exemple
brad pitt brad pitt loua les normes et
yachts je regrettais en thaïlande il
avec sa femme ses enfants et il part
dans une crique éveillant vallier la
veut la faire donc il part sur un bateau
mais se doute bien qu'il ya des gardes
du corps énorme avec des jumelles qui
regarde partout dont kiel où un bateau
ils payent cimf hyper joly qui monte sur
le bateau en maître pays parte up et y
mettre le matin petit peu alors raconté
tout brad pitt et les filles plonge
s'éclate dans la langue parlant
thaïlandais lui et planqueel crève de
chaud dans le bateau et que toute petite
fenêtre et il attend et une fois que les
gardes du corps sont rassurés ce bon sa
part thaïlandais c'est les meufs qui
s'amusent laisse passer une heure et ça
et au bout d'une heure ils fait les
photos et c'est notamment là d'ailleurs
l'un de ses fils ce cast bras et là la
photo ou le fils de mai sont que
l'ingéniosité vous avez pas me faire
baptiser un sébastien il a commencé chez
nous c'est non seulement la relève mais
c'est franchement un des meilleurs de la
profession alors il fait absolument
alors je remarque est plus grande plus
grande planque isabelle adjani ctek east
et vous pascal remarquer planque la plus
longue de mois isabelle adjani ah oui
c'est retient j'ai oublié c'est la plus
longue c'était marlon brando à
mais à part brando adjani c'était avec
warren beatty oui on l'a et donc ça
avait commencé à paris après c'était
parti à new york ouais c'est vrai que ça
avait duré deux mois oui vous avez tepa
paradis justement c'est ce que j'allais
dire moi je remets en question un petit
peu les compétences de la nouvelle
génération des paparazzi parce que
peut-être que laurent ruquier les
intéresse absolument pas parce qu'en
quatre ans de relation à tout jamais ce
questionnement je m'en fous mais je suis
assez surpris qu'en quatre ans en ayant
fait le tour du monde sans jamais se
cacher enfin c'était quand même j'ai
laissé plein indices au fur et à mesure
des cadres
comme un joli parce qu'en fait moi j'ai
absolument rien contre le métier de
paparazzi c'est amusant et puis c'est le
revers de la médaille doc a pas de
problème mais en quatre ans rien du tout
et c'est moi qui doit venir le déjà fait
40 ans que les habitants
[Applaudissements]
je parle sous le contrôle de pascal et
daniel c'est que c'est vrai que c'est un
métier qui a énormément changé elle a
beaucoup moins qu'avant aujourd'hui dans
paris je parle pas forcément de ceux qui
sont sous contrat ils sont peut-être dix
ou quinze là où ils pouvaient gagner
trente mille euros par mois en bossant
bien évidemment il ya encore quelques
temps aujourd'hui un paparazzi qui gagne
5 6000 euros à l embauche en sept jours
sur sept et et en mangeant dans sa
voiture dont le métier a énormément
changé les raisons ya peut-être avec
cinq places avec sa
communication doit tous les matins ce
que barack obama ou mick jagger a pris
au petit déjeuner donc ça devient très
très compliqué en plus si tu parles de
l'évolution du métier nous on a commencé
à une époque où c'était totalement
différent je vais pas parler d'élégance
mais les gens qui ont photographié
c'était grace kelly jacqueline kennedy
alors maintenant ça y est
c'est parti de l'environnement des
célébrités on se connaissait il nous
parlait aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
n'importe quelle petite starlette de la
téléréalité fines lames exactement dans
le sens le k2 dans le cas de laurent ok
il ne partage absolument pas sa vie
privée donc du coup j'ai envie de dire
c'est le client idéal pour aller c'est
de chercher des infos les amel bent ou
sa bombe on a
quelque chose totalement différent c'est
que tout ce qui concerne l'homosexualité
voilà ça ne peut pas passer nos
meilleurs spas d'amour panne et ça c'est
pas considéré comme une révélation
aujourd'hui encore c'est considéré comme
une dénonciation
d'un clip on est out et philippe ont été
ajoutés dans closer c'est sacré rien à
voir avec le long il assume depuis
toujours qu'il est homosexuel en parlez
pas de vodka mais effectivement wii et
sa manette que vous est peut-être que
toile et les paparazzi ne savent pas que
tu l'assument et blues florent fini pour
lui
mais pas pour le pardon des bons rails
c'est hyper intéressant
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
ces trois heures il ya quelques années j
étais pas mais c'est vrai que ça a créé
un précédent aujourd'hui certains
concurrents certains journaux
s'interdisent de mètres de parler
d'homosexualité en tout cas de mettre
des photos d'homosexuels qui ne sont pas
forcément présents termine elle déclaré
et on peut parler aussi d'adel
qui a été particulièrement je dis bien
angèle adele
qui l'a extrêmement mal pris traumatisée
bouleverser ses maquettes journal avait
sorti les photos m mais non c'est vrai
que les photographes des agences sont
tous très attention à ça c'est quelque
chose hein faut
qu'on fasse rentrer aussi par nommer
quelqu'un qui est avec lui qui connaît
bien les stars aussi de rentrer sur
poutine mais pas rentrer aussi sur les
stars c'est pas bien de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue
on va décaler le footing mais c'est
tellement passionnant pour bientôt tu es
tellement passionnant je sais pas du
tout j'adore je ratais pmp connaît mille
invités ils sont tous ça pour moi parce
que fabien c'est parce que j'aimerais
dire un mot quand même sur les photos
interdites dans france c'est à dire
celles que vous ne pouvez pas vendre en
france et qu'on retrouve à l'étranger
yonath à des photos comme ça daniel
barritt jupin couler des photos pardon
qui sont interdites en france que vous
faites que ne vous pouvez pas vendre en
france et qui se retrouvent à l'étranger
je parlé tout à l'heure de zidane on l'a
vu en train de fumer et se retrouve à la
une de données même avec moi il faut
savoir que pascal travaille encore moins
ya plus de dix ans que j'ai arrêté la
profession très nombreux mais c'est vrai
pas pu faire l'amour
tout repeint on parlait du cru et qui
avait été piégé on l'a dit par la
principauté machin ça c'est un truc
qu'on n'a pas vu en france et qu'on a vu
en italie en espagne
à caillé avec 15 15 pages de photos il
faut hélas je trouvais la fille
tellement magnifique elle qui est née
après pardon il forme était bronzé si
pardon pardon florian mais il ya aussi
des lignes éditoriales des journaux qui
n'ont pas se fâcher avec la famille de
la copa ce que te fâche et qui monaco sa
valeur pendant deux ans qui fera plus
aucune fois tu shootes pas etc tout ça
est très politique derrière on a l'air
de dire que c'est d'ailleurs il ya
closer qui avait sorti les photos de
kate middleton fin news avait fait un
scandale il avait pris une amende
gigantesque et du coup ils ont sorti sur
un autre magazine qu'ils ont dans leurs
maisons mères les italiens ben voilà
est-ce que tu as des photos justement
qui sont sortis pascal pas en france
mais qui ont été interdites en france et
qui sont sortis dans d'autres pays de
photos mais je me souviens de la photo
on parlait de beats tout à l'heure de
descoings de beats la photo du coin on
ne peut pas aller plus à la poêle et
donc il y avait le prince charles à poil
et c'était la couverture du journal qui
en italie et il avait fait quoi sur sa
[ __ ] il avait mis cet homme pascal
complexe
mais cette commission sur son membre
royal
vous avez vu la couronne anglaise
couronne d'angleterre tu sais comme les
jeux à gratter
aujourd'hui ce numéro non gratae en
italique vaudin d'euros
il ya des scoops en nul s'est découvert
bien sûr je suis découvert en allemagne
quand mon mari vers l'allemagne dans les
années 90 ont montré la fille les
allemands pour les allemands la fille
d'yves montand entre guillemets si pour
eux c'était la fille d'yves montand et
plein de photos dont celle là fini
montant aurore accord
bien connue des paparazzades haut avec
des arts 2 ou 3 2 ou 3 alors justement
on va aussi parler du coup on va
enchaîner avec fabien du couvent a
remercié merci beaucoup daniel et merci
pascal d'avoir été avec nous on va
enchaîner sur
merci encore c'était super intéressant
merci beaucoup